the award to the Best Director will be  presented tonight by a man who was  himself several times won this award I  happen to know he would personally  prefer to have history remember him as a  songwriter but I'm going to ignore his  wishes and introduce him as the great  director that he is Leo McCarey  you should have played one of my songs  well the nominees for the best directed  film for 1950 All About Eve 20th Century  Fox Joseph L mankiewicz the asphalt  jungle  metro-goldwyn-mayer John Huston born  yesterday  Columbia George Cukor Sunset Boulevard  Dharma Billy Wilder and the third man  Selznick enterprises in association with  London films production limited Selznick  releasing organisation Selznick Inc an O  and the director Carol Reed now if we  can have a look at the envelope and the  winner Joseph Bell maker